in upstate New York there are two guys
creating some dangerous and risky
explosion all in the name of science
this is Ingo I Mingus under I work for
the Center for jihad Studies at the
University of Buffalo and this is Andrew
my name is Andrew harp I am a PhD
student at the University at Buffalo the
researchers studying a large scale
disaster
more specifically volcanic eruption
currently we work on an experiment on
explosive magnet water interaction but
there's a problem
there's no lava in upstate New York
though they made their own they start
with rock 50 to 60 kilograms of rock we
melted in our furnace this takes four
hours roughly the rock liquefies and can
reach more than 2,300 degrees Fahrenheit
we then pour the molten rock from the
furnace into the container and into that
container we inject water and hope that
the water interact traumatically with
polar molten rock it's almost impossible
without being there to understand how
much heat is put off by this lava I have
to wear a aluminized suit a jacket and
kind of pants I have to wear that for
protection from potential splashes and
most importantly from the heat radiation
that comes out there we want to
understand by the magma water
direction and that actually occurs in
explosive volcanic eruptions the goal
would be to be able to predict exactly
the size and timing of the reaction that
we have I feel fortunate to be working
with something that's so unique that
it's only done in a few places in the
entire world right now maybe at the
forefront of this research is great
[Music]